hey guys chastity here at PAX East 2017
we saw so many cool games a lot of great
cosplay the overwatch cosplay was out of
control this year so much cool stuff so
if you want to see all of our packs
coverage you have to subscribe so do it
right now very nice now let's see what
the rest of the team liked about taxis
2017 so I saw some really beautiful
games from some really small teams but
my favorite thing was actually Final
Fantasy 15 upcoming DLC episode
gladiolus it focuses entirely on
gladiolus as he does this trial in a
cavern to prove that he's worthy of
being the shield of the king it's a nice
way to spend time with a character who
wasn't really the star of Final Fantasy
15 we also got a chance to talk to some
of the developers from square about the
game which was great we got some insight
not only into this DLC managing the
upcoming other character focused DLCs as
well just really great so the two games
I want to talk about are both Indies
coming to the Nintendo switch very soon
the first one is graceful explosion
machine to shoot them up super colorful
you get all these fun weapons you've got
like a sore that spins around your ship
for crowd control you've got this
long-range beam it's a lot of fun and
you're going to need something to play
after Zelda so check that one out and
the second game I'm gonna talk about is
mr. shifty if you like hotline Miami
you're gonna feel right at home here cuz
it plays very similarly but mr. shifty
as his name implies can shift through
walls and solid objects so sort of like
a last-second escape rope you can use
just before a bullet hits you and kills
you because it will kill you in one hit
my favorite thing at PAX East was a game
called sundered it's a Metroidvania
style game with procedurally generated
elements so different areas look
different enemies spawn in different
ways but it's still very much a
Metroidvania so as you progress you're
going to be unlocking new weapons new
skills that will allow you to progress
through the level it's really dark
really cool and it's something you're
gonna want to check out so if you want
to see more of the games that we just
talked about check out gamespot com and
I'll see you next time